hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of thrones if you'd like to
watch the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash GameSpot but if you
continue to watch here be aware of
spoilers let's kick off with my new
favorite couple let's just talk about
tormund Giantsbane and Brienne of Tarth
but why are they really called Giants
the bear and the maiden fair so I think
like this for me as well because you
read the books you kind of get more of
an insight into Brienne and just kind of
how tragic her life has been like she's
she's mockingly referred to as Brienne
the beauty because in the book she's you
know
Gwendoline Christie is my goodness like
I love that woman but like in the books
obviously right Brienne is meant to have
really bad crooked teeth and she's meant
to be just hideous so the call of
Brienne the beauty constantly mocked as
a child her betrothed dies and then at
one point her dad just sort of gives up
on trying to marry off to people even
though she's the only heir of the house
Toth and it's also sad like she gets all
dressed up and these these big bullies
like just you know just completely rip
her a new one and just call her awful
names and like that's why she falls in
love with Renly because he's the only
one who ever showed her like a hint of
kindness so basically seeing tormund
like he sees her for the first time in
his first reaction is oh yeah that
eyebrows going and he's eating what
looks like a burrito in a very sexual
way
yeah I think you could be this this
Mexican food at the war know maybe
everything is all about that thing is
just first of all like Brienne's
reaction cuz i guess she never takes
that stuff seriously right she's she's
got that arm and she's like mm-hmm
but then Dolores said it's just like
alright hey hey what's this gonna happen
matchmaker ed so do we think other of DB
vice and David Benioff are they gonna
give us just just like a little bit of
happiness
this better not be a one episode like
little funny thing I want this to be a
full-blown romance I want an entire
episode devoted to their courtship and
their marriage and their babies
des I think they're just gonna probably
fight and have a lot of sex
Oh Dave what he's like he's a wildling
and she's just wants to she's just
protecting sunset 20 ship Giantsbane
okay if he can make it with a giant then
you know he's a different kind of drones
being trained is that he killed the
giant you made it on a bane though in
May so Tom and always says that he he
had it off with a bear yeah but um
Ygritte said that like not that of
course I didn't have those biologically
um but it's interesting like thinking
about this the bear and the maiden fair
is like it's a song with in Game of
Thrones it's the title of an episode and
there's a lot of kind of parallels like
if you see in the relationship like oh
you and Hound and the Hound to be the
bear and she would be the maiden fair
but this one it's like Brienne's finally
the maiden fair she's got her bare
Tolman's probably got a lot of diseases
though she can wash him
you